well I mean she is a very difficult
challenge in that there that there's a
whole rule book on how to be a regular
guy but there's no such rule book on how
to be a regular gal in fact for for all
things considered I went out and I asked
people about this what sport what
activity they wanted to see her pursue
to make her more likable people at very
definite opinions a lot of people wanted
her to just scrap book which is wildly
popular you know uh-uh need to see her
Bowl somebody wanted her to be a dolphin
caller or something which a whale caller
and a dolphin trainer or something so uh
it's very difficult because it is she
doesn't have a model uh you know Ann
Richards is the closest model that
exists and ann richards i lived in texas
when she was running for reelection and
lost to george w bush but all her all of
her ads featured her hunting that's a
more regional thing but it was a way for
her to be seen as kind of a tough lady
you know is who could be who could be an
executive a commander in chief of in
this case her state this is at the core
of what I think is so funny about
presidential politics is the bad acting
people trying to convince you that
they're just like you and me and they're
not they can't be because their lives
are consumed with fundraising and with
with you know with wheeling and dealing
but that's the fun of it is is how you
know is looking at John Kerry in the
middle of a country music band strumming
a guitar and looking ridiculous with the
big cowboy hat or going duck hunting
when you know sorry I mean he was played
there for the foie gras but uh the UH
but these the you know the bush clearing
brush this nonsense some politicians are
just better actors & others are just
better able to convince you and me that
their regular people and uh and I know
that Bill Maher has said I don't want a
regular person in the White House I
understand what he's saying but people
want that they want somebody that they
can relate to but it has to be very
carefully calibrated because do you want
somebody that scratches himself because
you do that no you don't want that but
you also don't want somebody that wind
surfs
because that's two up there so it's
about finding that level and to me
that's hysterically funny watching them
reach for it